barbara walters after 50-plus years
doing network television she has
announced her retirement
and earlier this week on The View she
actually gave us a date
let's take a look you may remember that
last spring I said that I would leave
daily television
any year so here we are it's almost one
year later
and I have decided that Friday May 16
will be my final appearance on The View
as a cost
Co them
for will be a two-hour ABC news
primetime special
looking back at my career for all the
time 15 continuous years on their
tho
man i've been doing to YouTube job for a
year and I think that's a long time
fifty consecutive years on air so what
about Barbara
first and then we'll talk about the view
why is it that barbara walters doesn't
get into that gay
icon status that these older women seem
to get into a course for me the Golden
Girls
but all there's just plenty about older
women I
you know judy garland whoever that the
gate me let for some reason barbara
walters even though she's a proponent of
gay rights and is on TV every day and
talking about liberal causes
thing like that she never made it there
for some reason why does I find it hard
to trust anyone with eyes that are just
that day
it work but if you don't have a problem
with the woman with work Amanda
now yeah I don't know I think that she
comes across as like a little
pretentious at the same time I
appreciate the barriers that she is
broken down and that she was like really
at the forefront
what she was doing I'm by I just don't
feel like the
same warm fuzzy and how much she kinda
threats music on
to help kinda Wow time stroll
NRA to that point is that is it partly
because she's a newswoman
so she's more serious than gays like
over the top
great days like amp yet she doesn't have
a drag doppelganger
i think is nothing apart and you're
right it's hard to impersonate her and i
cant all our icons are performers
mostly yeah the easier to emulate and
Betty White is a comedian even though
she's not a thinker
yeah but shouldn't we love someone like
barbara walters who did break down all
those barriers and is actually doing
something i mean she did
she did for women what we want someone
to do
for gay people are I think we do amor I
love her I highly respect her I think
she's fears as hell the way she like
rain then
the view in like ok but Ochoa both down
at least about a lot brings a man and
hey I think people really respect your I
certainly really adore her and I think
she is back I had to be inspiration on
very ambitious I i buy
thank you I never thought about this but
yeah she's difficult to
Icona I whatever whatever that word is
that it was alright let's talk with the
manual because I i think there's
something really fascinating with the
view and gay people I
there was a couple years where i watch
with you every day when rosie was on my
enjoy it was on I they were so amazing
together there
rosy obviously is gay joy is as close to
gay as possible I get out to be a day
I am what is it about the view and what
is it about a group of women that are
outspoken
that gays are allowed because if they
were to show up by gay guys sitting
around table for gay guys
case would not be in doubt we will ever
but also what is that what is that
well I think that by I like to watch it
because I to see how a disinterested
enjoy is
instances like trying to get through the
shower this is just like is this really
another week video the base probably why
she left review after
what we're shooting for 12 years and I
gotta yeah its a
I think you can't pay all gay people the
broad-brush that like all the people
like the view
but it's the same reason why people like
the video its it's a distraction from
everyday life
like there's a lot of drama there's a
lotta cattiness that goes on
yeah and and you know people people like
that but it was in a meeting
where yeah yeah I click on a link to
this link
meaning was okay at a %uh okay right
what is it you know about what I said
though about gay guys
that I are you guys with me that it had
been a table for gay guys that it never
would have died nearly as well as having
women
I maybe middle age women would have
liked it
I was middle-aged women love gay guys
but that gay guys would have been
as into it if it had been gay guys at
the table I heard I think it's I think
there's not as wide appeal
if it's all just game and but that's a
cultural thing for another year another
side conversation what i'm talking
about. board game and watching it what
what why is it that gay men would be
more inclined to watch
a group of women at a table then game at
a table I think it's the same reason why
game and club back from the city cuz
that show
does were gay men masquerading as women
I think vida
the captive the view all those are gay
man masquerading as women I think this
comes they just remind us I'll
private conversation that we have I
think we love the fashion we love the
hair with there's a there's a certain
element love go I am and and it it
elevated it heightened it our lives
heightened
for you now and now you're right we
campaign it with the bitter big brush
but
it their appeal is the same reason that
the reality shows have appeal yeah and
fashion shows
have appeal so so there you go yeah
iight final thought on that I was
thinking you know barbara said the thing
about the the fifty years and all that
do you think that's just like a thing
that's a long time people that are going
to have the sourdough
iconoclastic i think is the word there
was a rumour
careers where they last 50 years in the
business
is she really wanted the sorta for and
when a caller dinosaur but you know what
I mean is she
is that it really that we won't have
people that last this long in this kinda
business
well I mean it up I don't think so i
think there's going to be other people
that they're doing that but the
important thing with Barbara Walters is
really she broke down so many
barriers that stood in her way that
lately in that sense she's
legendary much she did right and there
will be other people the front other
game doing things have never been done
but those were some like really
big walls to break down yeah so I get
there aren't that many walls to break
down
hope do right now I think deeper was it
just the pop-up not refer her
right now separate or copper people up
her you know
not for white women in broadcasting
record here the other words to break
down